A QUICK CONVICTION MAY SHOW THAT
RUSSIA AND PUTIN ARE TRYING TO
KEEP THIS ARREST AWAY FROM
HEADLINES.
>> Reporter: BRAVELY PROTESTING
RUSSIA'S WAR IN UKRAINE.
HER BANNER, NO WAR.
DO NOT BELIEVE THE PROPAGANDA.
THEY TELL YOU LIES HERE.
SEEN LIVE BY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF RUSSIANS ON THE
STATE'S PRIME PROPAGANDA
CHANNEL.
RUSSIA WON.
IN COURT THE FOLLOWING DAY,
FOUND GUILTY OF AN
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFENSE,
ORGANIZING AN UNAUTHORIZED
EVENT, FINED 280,000 RUBLES,
ABOUT 280EDLIES.
NOT FOR STORMING THE SET BUT A
MESSAGE SHE POSTED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA PRIOR.
>> DON'T BE AFRAID.
THEY CAN'T ARREST US ALL.
>> Reporter: RUSSIA HAS BANNED
ALL ANTIWAR PROTESTS, BUT THEY
CONTINUE.
MORE THAN 900 ARRESTED THIS PAST
WEEKEND.
MOST GETTING A BEATING, A FINE,
AND OVERNIGHT DETENTION.
UNCLEAR IF THE KREMLIN IS TRYING
TO MINIMIZE HER EXTRAORDINARY
PRIME-TIME PROTEST OR IF SHE'LL
FACE STIFFER CHARGES LATER.
INITIALLY STATE MEDIA REPORTED
INVESTIGATORS WERE CONSIDERING
CHARGES UNDER RUSSIA'S NEW
DRACONIAN LAWS THAT PROHIBIT
WHAT IT CALLS DISSEMINATING
FALSE INFORMATION ABOUT RUSSIAN
FORCES AND CAN CARRY A MAXIMUM
15-YEAR JAIL SENTENCE.
HER FATHER APPEARS TO BE
EXPECTED TO BE SILENCED.
HER PRERECORDED SOCIAL MEDIA
POST PULLING NOW PUNCHES.
>> Reporter: RUSSIA IS THE
AGGRESSOR COUNTRY, AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS
AGGRESSION LIES IN THE
CONSCIENCE OF ONLY ONE PERSON.
THIS MAN IS VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Reporter: THE QUESTION FOR
SOME NOW IS HER PROTEST AN
INDICATION THAT PUTIN'S PROP
BEGAN GAMMA CLEAN IS FAILING?
>> IT SHOWS A CHANGE IN THE MOOD
OF THOSE WORKING ON RUSSIA STATE
TV.
>> Reporter: TOO SOON TO SAY IF
CRACKS ARE OPENING UP, BUT
RUSSIA'S THIRD TOP RATED CHANNEL
TV LOST AN ALL-TIME ANCHOR.
SHE REPORTEDLY TOLD A RUSSIAN
BLOGGER SHE RESIGNED AND HAS
LEFT THE COUNTRY, SAYING SHE WAS
AFRAID THEY WOULDN'T LET HER GO.
N TV HAS DECLINED TO COMMENT.
THEY SHOW HOW MANY RUSSIANS
REMAIN TO PUT THEIR LIBERTY ON
THE LI